hello
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if
okay
okay
thank you thank you so much
facebook
just
we'll give you something
wow
okay let's press
yep
shoulder
okay
what's up
now
oh
oh
[Music]
so
up
good
[Music]
so
uh
okay
so
so
okay
[Music]
tell them four by four
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
just get comfortable up there
[Music]
already
[Music]
[Laughter]
here
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen
our trump song
the drum
and all our drums right across turtle
island
it is a symbol of the heartbeat of
mother earth it's a symbol of the
heartbeat of each and every one of us we
have a heartbeat
it represents the heartbeat of all
animals and living things
so it is very powerful it's healing
and
again it is a very special afternoon to
be able to witness this and have this
very sacred song
introduce
our visitor
so at this time we're going to go into
what we call an entry we're going to be
honoring our chiefs
they will be coming in from the east
side will be our current chiefs and to
the south will be our former chiefs
so at this time we're going to go into a
grand entry song what do we call a grand
entry song
singers take a book
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
ladies a little bit
ladies and gentlemen
our gifts
every nation has an eagle staff
we have our eagle staffs leading our
grand entry procession
the eagle staff
represents
our sovereignty
our nations
are represented
by the eagle staffs
the history
the history of our nations are
represented with our eagle staffs
at this time we're going to be coming in
and calling in
our great chiefs
our great chiefs wearing the war bonds
our war bonnets
are very sacred to us
war bonnets
represent leadership
leadership
of our nation
leadership
amongst all our nations
the
the war bonded the eagle bonnet
represents
who we are
as a nation
so right here we got our four nations
chiefs coming in at this time
again welcome
to musco cheese
we have our four chiefs our four nations
chiefs and also our grand chief
wilkin dr wilton little child
[Laughter]
the sun
is one of the most powerful things the
creator has given us as people first
nations people
we acknowledge the sun
for healing
and health
oh yeah
[Music]
so right now we have our former chiefs
we also have
[Music]
represented here we have all the chiefs
within our territory 326 territory and
also visiting chiefs from other first
nations
in the war bonnets
against
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
bye
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
[Applause]
let's give everybody a round of applause
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen over here we have
our ogimawa we have also have our eagle
staff the eagle staffs represent our
warriors we have to defend our
territories our warriors had to defend
the language our warriors had to defend
children
grandchildren
we had to
defend our language and to defend our
way of life so these reference these
eagle staff represent that and also the
war bonnets they represent leadership so
this time we're going to honor our eagle
staffs and the war bonnets our chiefs
with the flag
song sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hey
hi
thank you very much they're singers i'm
going to ask you to sing one more song
okay do you have the victory song there
singers
sing us the victory song as we honor you
know we've been here
since time memorial
and
it's 2022 and we still have our way of
life we still have our language we're
going to continue on living our way of
life it's only going to get better this
is what we call our victory sangha here
at this time wow
we'll have our eagle snaps our chiefs
warriors where's your workfall
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
once again warriors
let's hear your war call
it's celebration
[Music]
one more time
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey hey hi hi
[Music]
[Applause]
okay gentlemen you can come to eagle
staffs there we have uh areas we're
gonna post our
staffs and we'll have uh
all our chiefs come back here
we're gonna go into a healing uh a
healing test here at this time as soon
as we have our eagle staff situated
right around the
center pole here
it
certainly represents life
from the beginning it never ends
i'm going to continue that journey so
again
the center pole
we have one of our biggest ceremonies
where we have
what we call the king tree
stands in the middle of our lodge and
all our nation's people come there to
show the creator
and
you know they have to go through
a three-day four-day fast where they're
gonna dance without food and water but
this uh arbor you see he represents that
lodge
and uh
gentlemen who can make you up to the
front
and all the dignitaries there is seating
in front for you all hey
me
[Music]
okay yeah
oh my god
yep
so ladies and gentlemen we do
have a lot of
survivors here
and
this is a very historic event and they
wanted to be here and we're asking
everybody if you could just
be seated be seated please ladies and
gentlemen
because people want to watch i know we
have uh the big screens out there but
we do really want to
watch him
as he
makes us uh
and
what what he's gonna talk about here's
quick
okay quickly everybody you can clear the
area
[Music]
i'll go up there
we've got a couple of gentlemen here
we're here so veterans
they're missing their chairs so we can
help them out
and everybody make a nice circle
we have people inside the circle
kind of back back up
everyone back up
okay
foreign
[Music]
at this time go to our
sacred drum here with our singers
they're going to sing a special song
again and this is what we are going to
be calling the healing dance they'll
sing the healing song and we're going to
have our our dancers then within this
circle
and this will be all about healing and
the drum is a big part of the healing
it's the heartbeat of mother earth the
drum is life
[Music]
ah
keep on walking there
keep on walking
and security if you want to kneel down
kneel down up to the side so people can
watch
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
you know ladies and gentlemen
the number four
represents
the elements
four
directions the four stages of life
the poor
the poor living life forms
partnerships
we have the sun rising
from the east
and we also have from the south
we have the thunderbird
and over on the west side
we have the wind
the oxygen that we breathe
on the north side we have mother earth
mother earth is
who we are mother earth
is
all the plant life
mother earth
our mother
is also
the mother of all insect life
mother earth
is also the mother
of all animals on the ground in the
water in the air
mother earth
of course
is the mother of all
humanity
mother earth especially
our children
we are the people of mother earth
hi
[Music]
so
one more time ladies and gentlemen let's
acknowledge our dancers
hi hi hi hi all right they're dancers
you can uh find a place up there and
we're gonna go
we're gonna go
next in our program here
your holiness
fancy watkin
it's great honor
to welcome us
you have traveled a long way
to be with us on our land
and to walk
with us
on the path of reconciliation
for this
we honor you
and extend to you
our most heartfelt welcome
we wish to acknowledge with deep
appreciation
and gratitude
the great personal effort
you have made
to travel to our land
it is a blessing
to receive
and host you
among us
the vast expanse of
land called
[Music]
canada
and we see indigenous peoples referred
to as part of turtle island
is the traditional
homeland for the first nation
haiti
and
indian peoples
here in muscat
we are on 3d6 land
the ancestral territory of the cree
dna
blackfoot
soto
and nakota sue peoples since time
immemorial
my name
in cree is
the wolf walker
they go out
golden eagle in english
i am known as wilton
little child
i was a student here
at the erinskin indian residential
school
which for your visit
among us this day
represents all the residential schools
in our country
gathered here this morning
with the peoples of massachusetts
our residential school survivors
chiefs
leaders
elders
knowledge keepers
and youth
from first nations metis and inuit
communities across our land
we feel particularly honored
to welcome
as well
the governor general of camp
correctly mary simon
and the prime minister
the right honorable
justin trudeau
as a former commissioner
as a former commissioner truth and
reconciliation commission
i have heard nearly seven thousand
testimonies
from former students of residential
schools in this country
during the recent visit to your home at
the vatican
by a delegation of indigenous survivors
elders knowledge keepers
and youth
you also heard
of the abuses so many of us
have suffered
at this
and other residential schools
during our time with you
it was clear to us all
that you listened
deeply and with great compassion
to the testimonies that told of the way
our languages
were suppressed
our culture
taken from us
and
our spirituality
denigrated
our spirituality
denigrated
you have heard the devastation that
followed
from the way our families were torn
apart
the words you spoke to us in response
clearly came from the depths of your
heart
and were for those who heard them
a source of deep comfort
and great encouragement
on that occasion
you express your intention to vis visit
with us on our land
and in this way
express your strong desire
to be close to us
and now your holiness
you have come to our land
in response to our invitation
and as you promised
you have said that you have come as a
pilgrim
seeking to walk together
justice
healing
reconciliation
and hope
we gladly welcome you
to join us on this journey
as you acknowledged in your address to
us in rome
we indigenous peoples
strive always
to consider them
[Music]
the present events
and deliberations
on future
generations
in that spirit
we sincerely hope
that our encounter this morning
and the words share with us
will echo
real hope
throughout many generations to come
your holiness
welcome our land
[Applause]
oh
this
[Music]
mr prime minister
dear indigenous peoples of moscowicis
and of this land of canada
dear brothers and sisters
i have been waiting to come here and be
with you
here
from this place associated with painful
memories
i would like to begin what i consider a
pilgrimage
a penitential pilgrimage
i have come to your native lands
to tell you in person of my sorrow
to implore god's forgiveness
healing and reconciliation
to express my closeness
and to pray with you
and for you
[Music]
[Music]
alive
we
conciliation i recall the meetings we
had in rome for months ago
at that time
i was given two pairs of moccasins
as a sign of the spring insured by
indigenous children
especially those who unfortunately
never came back home from the
residential schools
i was asked to return the moccasins when
i came to canada
i brought them
and i will do so at the end of these few
words
in which i would like to reflect on this
symbol
which over the past few months
has kept alive my sense of sorrow
indignation
and shame
the memory of those children is indeed
painful
it urges us to work
to ensure that every child is treated
with love
honor and respect
at the same time
those moccasins
also speak to us of a path to follow
a journey that we desire to make
together
we want to walk together
to pray together and to work together
so that the sufferings of the past can
lead to a future of justice
healing and reconciliation
yesterday
following ways of life
in harmony with all that
takes place in this region
which from tamim immemorial
has seen the presence of indigenous
peoples
these are lands that speak to us
they enable us to remember
to remember brothers and sisters
you have lived on these lands for
thousands of years
following ways of life that respect the
earth which you received as a legacy
from past generations
and are keeping for those yet to come
you have treated it as a sign of the
creator to be shared with others and to
be cherished in harmony with all that
exists
in profound fellowship
with all living beings
in this way
you learn to foster a sense of family
and community
and to build
generations
honoring your elders
and caring for your little ones
a treasury of some customs and teachings
centered on concern for others
truthfulness
courage and respect
humility
and practical wisdom
those
opportunities
is
as i speak
yet
if these if those were the first steps
taken in these lands
the path of remembrance
leads us sadly to those that followed
the place where we are gathered
renews within me the deep sense of pain
and remorse
that i have felt in these months
i think i
of the tragic situations that so many of
you
your families and your communities have
known
of what you shared with me about the
suffering you endured in the residential
schools
these are trusts
that are in some way reawakened
whenever the subject comes up
i realized too that our meeting today
can bring back old memories and hurts
and that many of you
may feel uncomfortable even i speak
yet
it is right to remember
because forgetfulness
leads to indifference
and
as has been said
the opposite of love is not hatred
it's indifference
and the opposite of life
is not death
it's indifference
to remember
the devastating experiences
that took place in the residential
schools hurts
angers
causes pain
and yet
it is necessary
it is
[Music]
forms of spirituality
indigenous
grandparents and grandchildren it is
necessary to remember how the policies
of assimilation and enfranchisement
which also included the residential
school system were devastating for the
peoples of these lands
when the european colonists first
arrived here
there was a great opportunity
bring about a fruitful encounter between
cultures
traditions and forms of spirituality
yet
for the most part
that did not happen
again
i think back on the stories you told
how the policies of assimilation ended
systematically
marginalizing the indigenous peoples
how also through the system of
residential schools your languages and
cultures were denigrated and suppressed
how children suffered physical
verbal
psychological and spiritual abuse
how they were taken away from their
homes at a young age
and how that indelibly affected
relationships between parents and
children
grandparents and grandchildren
foreign
still open
[Music]
regrettably
i thank you
for making me appreciate this for
telling me about the heavy burdens that
you stare
for sharing with me
these bitter memories
today
i am here
in this land
that along with it ain't with its
ancient memories
preserves the scars
of still open wounds
i am here
as the first step of my penitential
pilgrimage among you
is that of again asking forgiveness
of telling you once more
that i am deeply sorry
sorry
[Applause]
sorry for the ways in which regrettably
many christians supported
the colonizing mentality of the powers
that oppress indigenous peoples
i am sorry
i ask forgiveness
[Applause]
i ask forgiveness in particular for the
ways in which many members of the church
and of religious communities cooperated
not least through their indifference
in projects of cultural destruction and
forced assimilation
promoted by the governments of that time
which culminated in the system of
residential schools
catastrophic
of jesus christ
[Music]
yes
against the indigenous peoples
although christian charity was not
abstinent
and there were many outstanding
instances of devotion and care for
children
the overall effects of the policies
linked to the residential schools were
catastrophic
what our christian faith tells us
is that this was a disastrous error
incompatible with the gospel of jesus
christ
it is painful
to think of how the firm's soil of
values
language and culture that made up the
authentic identity of your peoples was
eroded
and that you have continued to pay the
price for this
in the face of this deplorable evil
the church kneels before god
and implores his forgiveness
for the sins of her children
i myself
wish to reaffirm this
with shame
and unambiguously
i humbly beg forgiveness
for the evil committed by so many
christians
against the indigenous peoples
dear brothers and sisters
[Applause]
[Music]
starting
use
[Music]
dear brothers and sisters
many of you and your representatives
have stated that begging pardon
is none of the matter
i fully agree
that it's only the first step
the starting point
i also recognize that looking to the
past
and you see to repair the harm done
will ever be sufficient
and that looking ahead to the future
no effort must be spared
to create a culture able to prevent such
situations
from happening
this process
will be to conduct a serious
investigation
into the facts of what took place in the
past
and to assist the survivors of the
residential schools
to experience healing from the traumas
they suffered
[Applause]
is
[Music]
is
i trust and pray
that christians and civil society in
this land
may grow in the ability to accept and
respect the identity he experienced
the indigenous peoples
it is my hope
that concrete ways can be found to make
those peoples better known and esteemed
so that all may learn to walk together
for my part
i will continue to engage the efforts
all catholics
to support the indigenous peoples
i have done so at various times and
occasions
through meetings appeals and also
through the writing of an apostolic
exhortation
i realize that all this will require
time and patience
we are speaking of processes that must
penetrate hearts
my presence here
and the commitment of the canadian
bishops
are
a testimony to our will to persevere on
this path
dear friends
over several
days distant from one another
invitations
like cameron
winnipeg
in my
words
dear friends
this pilgrimage is taking place over
several days
and in places far distant
from one another
even so
it will not allow
the main invitations i have received to
visit centers like kamloops
winnipeg
various places in saskatchewan yukon and
the northwest territories
nonetheless
please know that all of you are in my
thoughts and my prayer
know that i am aware of the sufferings
and traumas
the difficulties and challenges
experienced by the indigenous peoples
in every region of this country
the words that i speak throughout this
penitential journey are meant for every
native community and person
i embrace all of you with affection
help us
enable us to advance together on our
journey
on this first step of my journey
i have wanted to make space for memory
here today
i am with you to recall the past
to grieve with you
to bow our heads together in silence
and to pray before the graves
let us allow these moments of silence
to help us interiorize our pain
silence
and prayer
in the face of evil
we pray to the lord of goodness
in the face of death
we pray to the god of life
our lord jesus christ
took a grave which seemed the burial
place of every hope and dream
leaving behind only sorrow
pain and resignation
and made it a place of rebirth and
resurrection
the beginning of a history of new life
and universal reconciliation
our own efforts
are not enough to achieve healing and
reconciliation
we need god's grace
we need the quiet and powerful wisdom of
the spirit
the tender love of the comforter
may he bring
to fulfillments to fulfillment the
deepest expectations of our hearts
may he guide our steps
take us by the hand and enable us
to advance together
on our journey
that's good
right
thank you
[Applause]
yes
so
oh
this morning
this morning at the same time
honoring the person
that
stood up and
was able to
come and not only say i'm sorry but went
once and further and provided
some
form of you know
asking for forgiveness but at the same
time
moving forward and doing things for
those people
and
succeeding generations of those people
so it's with that we
sing this song again
for those children and for our great
leader and pope
um
[Music]
i
hey
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
hey
hey
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yay
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
discovery
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so
okay
so
but
so
easy
first
this
foreign
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
[Music]
officers
ah
hey
if i could have your attention
if i could kindly have your attention
i know everyone is anxious
you're the holy father
but we have some elders that were
invited to participate to offer the
whole father
gifts on behalf of all the survivors
and
so
we
were just concerned about safety it's
pretty tight up here at the stage if we
could just get people to move back just
a little bit for everyone's safety this
is a safety issue now huh so please
please respect we have survivors seated
who are anxious as well
to you know to to watch uh this event
and to appreciate this
[Music]
christ our lord
and say
our father
who art in heaven
halloween
the kingdom comes
from hell and it's in heaven
give us this day off
and forgive us no steps
our forgivers who trespass against us
led us not into the temperature but
from evil
the lord
within you
blessed by the nominee of the lord
our help
is in the name of the lord
may almighty god
the holy spirit
[Music]
and help me
god
foreign
you
amen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
what's
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rocky
[Music]
oh
and we're all done here for today we
thank you all for all your beautiful
remarks and etc but we love you all have
a safe trip home and thank you for
coming to moscow cheese hi hi
[Music]
go to the same exits and you'll get
transferred back to your vehicles thank
you
right
[Music]
[Music]
away thank you
[Music]